hello and welcome to the Evan Carmichael
show I believe in entrepreneurs I want
to see you have massive success with
your company and I'm really upset today
so I'm just gonna get right into it I'm
upset with the little man I'm upset with
the guy we all have a little man in our
life this is the guy who tells us that
you're not good enough that that hates
on your idea that tells you all the
reasons why your dreams are not going to
work out we all have these people in our
lives and they hold us back from
achieving massive success I have a story
today about a little man in my life
who's been causing me some grief and I
want to share that with you and talk to
you about how you can avoid and overcome
the fears and the doubts that little man
puts in your mind this is important
because I don't care about this little
man in my life right now I'm at the
point in my career where if you tell me
I'm not going to be successful at
something I'm going to go out and prove
you wrong
but the little man when you're first
getting started the little man is a
dream killer and it bothers me that
little man exists think about it when
you have a new idea for your your your
life your company right you're lying in
bed it's 2:00 in the morning you come up
with this great idea I'm gonna launch
this business and you have the courage
you have that courage for the brief
moment in time to say you know what I
can I can be more than I am right now I
can build a better life for myself that
takes guts that takes bravery and then
you wake up the next day and you still
have some doubts you have doubts cuz you
haven't figured it all out yet but
you're sitting down you're thinking no
what I really want to do this and so
you're going to tell your friends you
tell your family right who do you talk
to you about your new ideas and this is
where you know who's a true friend in
your life and who's just a little man
because the friends are going to be the
people who tell you go for I support you
I believe in you you can do this who
find the holes in your plan and help you
figure out ways to overcome them
because when you first come up with an
idea you have it all worked out right
it's just an idea right now it's a dream
you kind of you have a vision for what
you want to be but you don't quite know
how you're gonna get there your plan is
gonna be full of holes and that's okay
the little man is the guy who's gonna
come on and say you're not gonna do this
you're not good enough you're not gonna
make it look at all these holes in your
plans it's not going to work because of
this and this and this and this and this
that's what the little man does and he
puts doubt in your mind even if little
man has no idea what he's talking about
even if little man has no experience in
this the fact that little man doubts you
makes you doubt yourself you need to
believe in yourself in your vision in
what you stand for more than you believe
in the opinions of other people that's
why it's important because little man is
a dream killer because he has more
confidence in his wrong opinions than
you do in your idea and that makes you
shut down for that brief moment in time
when you have some courage to stand up
and do something more do something
greater
BAM little man smashes you back down to
an average life that's why I'm upset
today I'm upset at the little man in
everybody's life and we need to stop him
out so I'm working on this project it's
an online project and little man gets a
hold of it and he writes in to me and
this is what he write this is great this
is great he tells me please tell me you
actually understand how the internet
works this is what I write to me so let
me let me take a breath
you can tell I'm upset today now let me
back up a sec okay because I'm all for
criticism
I love criticism Chris's criticism helps
make you better it gives you ideas and
how you can become a better person a
better entrepreneur but you have to look
at the source you have to look at who's
telling you this
I believe that as entrepreneurs we're
gladiators you are a gladiator every day
you wake up and you go on you fight for
your business and you fight for a better
life and you fight for your family and
you're in the arena fighting
meanwhile you have all these people
around you watching a spectators
that's where little man sits up in the
crowd because he's too afraid to get in
the ring and he's there telling jokes
screaming at you laughing at you
throwing popcorn at you paying him no
mind you need to accept to listen to
criticism from people who've done it
before who know what they're talking
about
not the people were just confident in
their wrong opinions and try to put you
down so when someone writes in the mean
size please tell me you actually
understand how the internet works you
know what if that's coming from the
founders of Google or the founders of
Twitter or someone who I look up to in
the online world like Gary Vaynerchuk
those guys are writing to me saying that
then I'm gonna listen say hey guys
you've done a lot more than I have what
can I do tell me tell me how to get
better but if it's somebody who's never
done anything important in his life
I'm not letting his opinions get me down
why don't we just do a little comparison
okay me versus Liv I'm an online I've
got 20 million people who visited my
website little man a thousand degrees
lucky I've got 200,000 followers on
Twitter little man a couple thousand I'm
about to pass a million views on my
youtube channel little man's got a
couple thousands and here is little man
telling me that I don't understand how
the internet works
little man it's the guy up in the crowd
throwing popcorn down on you pay him no
mind
I don't care about this little man
because he's not changing my life I'm
not changing my decisions based on what
he's saying
the problem is he impacts a lot of you
and you may be second-guessing yourself
you may be questioning yourself and you
rethinking I don't know if I'm gonna be
able to do this or not you know maybe
little man is right I don't know what to
do that's what that's what bothers me if
you think about your dream as a precious
idea if I went to that little man before
head started if I said he was an idea I
have what do you think and all he did
was trash it did I would be stuck you
know I might I might doubt myself I
might say this isn't gonna work
maybe little man is right maybe I should
stop you need to believe in yourself
more than you believe in little man I
got a question from someone on Twitter
who wrote in to stay what if it doesn't
work out you know what if little man is
right what if it doesn't work out how do
I get over that fear to get going and
this is gonna happen you know what
success is not a straight line that's
not how it works it's not you come with
an idea and bloom you take off
there's a whole bunch of little failures
that are gonna happen before you end up
having success and anywhere along the
line in there you might shut down you
might feel the world is against you
you're never gonna make it if you look
at any successful company look at your
favorite successful entrepreneur whoever
it is whatever industry they're in you
look at how they got started the
business idea that they started with is
not the same as what made them
successful your business will always
change and anywhere along that curve is
you're growing you're starting this
company you have these assumptions that
you think it's gonna work you're gonna
get hit with the reality that a lot of
your assumptions are wrong and you could
stop right there you could stop there
and say you know what it's not working
out and when little man is criticizing
you and saying see I told you that was a
stupid idea
that might be enough to say you know
what I'm out I'm done I'm not gonna do
this anymore you need to find another
way to stand by getting out there and
talking to your customers and modifying
your business idea and adapting to the
changes if you really believe in what
you're doing if it's important to you
you'll find a way to make it successful
you look at every successful
entrepreneur they're not doing it
because they want to make a lot of money
you look at Oprah Winfrey Donald Trump
Bill Gates you name it the biggest
entrepreneurs in the world look at why
they started it wasn't to make a lot of
money it's because they had a deep
passion for what they're doing and that
passion gets you through it gives you
through all the hard times that passion
gets you through all the ups and downs
it gets you through the criticism that
you're gonna get when you go up against
little man so this show is all about how
to beat down that little man because he
is a cancer little man think small
little man can't see a vision little man
gets no joy in his own life so he's got
to put you down for you trying to be
great and whether he's jealous of you
whether he's afraid of you whatever it
is he doesn't want to be successful and
you can't let that hatred keep you down
over the course of my business in my
career I've had a lot of people who who
believed in me I've had my parents who
whenever I was down told me you know
whatever your Yorkist Raley Carmichael
you can do this and I grew up in a
family where I had that passionate
belief that I could do anything but
you're going to always run across that
little man who comes and tells you that
it's not possible that you can't do it
that you're not good enough you can't
listen to him you have to be stronger
than him
you have to know that what you're doing
is right that you will be successful but
even though you just see darkness all
around you you don't know how it's gonna
work out that's okay because you're
committed to making your business about
this exciting
here's the thing with little man okay
little man has to be right he has to be
right even if he doesn't know what he's
talking about he always has to be right
and he thinks small as entrepreneurs
we're big thinkers we're dreamers we
have a vision for what we want to do
when little man just can't see it
he's a small thinker so a little man
wrote to me and he was talking with my
idea and he was trying to convince me
that that it would never work out and he
wrote in they say that's what he says if
you zoom out you'll find that I'm right
this hilarious because this little man
is such a small thinker he wouldn't know
a big idea if it hit him right in the
face
and here he is telling me zoom out and
think bigger
my goal to help a billion entrepreneurs
what are you trying to do a little man
this guy's allergic to thinking big this
is the problem I can like this guy has
no impact in my life but people in your
life people who have no idea what
they're talking about how zero
experience of zero credibility will be
absolutely 100% convinced that what
you're doing is wrong and I have an
opinion on everything don't let those
people drag you down just because
they're confident in their wrong opinion
that doesn't mean that they're right
stand up for yourself believe in
yourself believe in your dream
let him be right and then go out and
prove them wrong I want to get to your
called I have Tony on the line Tony
thanks for waiting where are you from
and how can I help
I'm from uh Scottsdale Arizona and I've
got an idea to do a satellite centers
throughout the country okay LED light
treatment
yeah and absolutely works if it didn't
work I wouldn't be wasting my time okay
so what I do is I've got our machines
that actually melts the fat and you can
see a two-inch loss after your first
treatment so my idea is get some doctors
on board locate you know co-locate in
their office with them so he
my rent down and my initial investment
down and just to get the kid all
throughout the country I think I can
have 50 locations by on by the end of
the year so what's holding you back
money I need to find something I need to
bind to investors so how much is the
cost rent machine about fifty thousand
dollars per machine okay and why can't
the doctors put that up well you know if
you're the result with doctors doctors
are a notoriously bad businessman and
they're very cautious and how they do it
so I was wondering if you think that I
should go after a what do you think I
should get money from you think I should
go after a hedge fund people individual
investors or and what would go would be
your your idea for me to find the
capital do I need to start this okay so
I used to be in the venture capital
business to do some angel investing this
is not something that a head China's
going to look at it's not some kind of
VC is going to look at you're dealing in
the best case an angel investor the
challenge you're gonna have is showing
that it works right I was my first
reaction does this thing actually work
and I honestly I think your best bet is
going to be from getting
forward-thinking doctors yeah it's true
a lot of them suck at being a
businessman and that may be where you
can come in and help them a little bit
but there are there are quite a few who
are forward-thinking looking for ways to
grow their business are up-to-date on
technology and this is something they
would jump on like you're not going to
be able to help every single doctor in
the country right that's not your target
you want to go off the guys who get
technology who can sell this who
understand it who want to make more
money for forward-thinking and believe
in it I would be dust off in the you
know in what's a plastic surgeon in
their office because there's already got
existing clientele so that way I can I
can keep my advertising dollars down
right off the bat and I think it'd be
beneficial for both because when I do
spend money in advertising that though
I'm gonna get customers for them or
they're gonna get what they're gonna get
customers for me too so that's what I
was thinking you know that's what I was
thinking I would in the same way myself
with my thinking there you've got people
there who understand business plastic
surgeons
are much better businessman than a lot
of doctors and the best ones make a ton
of money so they have 50,000 all to them
is nothing you have the capital to
invest in this and you made to make it
easier want to consider working with
some kind of financial institution that
you can you can set up a payment plan so
they're not they're not fine 50k cash
upfront but you can get it - that's a
really good idea I like that idea so
it's like 100 bucks a month - 20 bucks a
month and if you can show them hey this
is going to make you 5k every week then
it's a no-brainer induction for them
absolutely that's you don't that's great
advice I really appreciate that now and
it's not you putting it on your business
and you having to have a great financial
they're putting it on their business
absolutely and I'll tell you your Segway
and I was listening earlier about the
little man anytime you start any type of
business I've learned in my lifetime and
I've been in multiple businesses
everybody there's gonna be a million
people out there they're gonna tell you
why it can't work you know your advice
was was excellent in it it really hit
home because everybody's like all you
can't do it they'll tell you this and
tell you that and you just really every
time what I've done in my life
is every time someone tells me no it
excites me and I want to work harder to
make it work to prove everybody wrong
yeah you got it Tony you got it you're
the entrepreneur thank you very much I
appreciate it
no problem thanks for calling in so for
everybody listening if you are going out
and trying to finance something yourself
it can be really hard right if you've
got a great idea you know you know it
can work you have a number of options
okay if it's a big big idea is how it's
going to make millions and millions then
you could talk about venture capital
funding those are the guys who have deep
pockets are going to finance you if it's
smaller than you're looking at going to
angel investors and these are wealthy
individuals people who have some money
people who are looking for opportunities
a lot of them are our doctors and
dentists I dealt with a lot of them
inside the industry it's called DDI
doctors or dentists with disposable
income and a lot of them are
so bored with their jobs their day-in
day-out that they're looking for
investment opportunities they want to
live vicariously through you so you can
go to those guys but also see if your
customers might be able to finance it in
Tony's case he's targeting these doctors
the plastic surgeons making a ton of
money those guys should be financing
this operation and you can potentially
get a finance by a financial institution
as well so they make those small monthly
payments instead of a huge chunk right
upfront so look for creative ways
bootstrapping
does it have to be you dipping into your
bank account mortgaging your home
risking everything putting it all on the
line there's always a creative way to
get something done and I hate spending
money until I'm making money so try to
use that as a principle I had with
Tony's thoughts on the little man he
hates little man - there's always gonna
be people who are trying to bring you
down tell you all the reasons why it's
not possible paid the little man boom ah
okay he's not important to your life he
adds no value he just brings you down
and that that might be a close family
member of yours or friends but you got
to think back to say there's this person
actually understand what he's talking
about
is this person actually qualified to
give me good advice or not and usually
it's not so ignore the haters focus on
your business believe in yourself
believe in your dream because if you can
keep that confidence to keep that
courage up you can build something
amazing today's show is all about
stomping out the little man in your life
the people who tell you that your idea
isn't good that you're never going to
make it that you should give up these
you should quit that you're not good
enough we all have these people in our
lives to try to bring us down Walker no
real value to us and I'm sharing some
stories about the little man in my life
so this is a great story you're gonna
like it I just launched this video okay
it's called believe it's a six minute
video it's a motivational video that
basically tells the story of people who
didn't believe in themselves who didn't
believe that their goal was
possible and that that small shift in
mindset that that change that gave them
a little bit of courage that said I
think I can do this when they when they
shifted that they were able to go and
accomplish great things it's six minutes
it's it's one of the things I'm most
proud of creating so far in my business
it's great and little man gets a hold of
it and he writes in the main he says
Evan videos on YouTube should not be
longer than three minutes your six
minute video it's too long it's never
going to work
he tells me Liberty rights the average
length of the top 50 videos on YouTube
was 2 minutes and 54 seconds therefore
the fact that your video is longer than
3 minutes means it's not going to work
and I read that out are you serious it's
like what planet did this guy just come
from it's unbelievable to me if you look
at the top 50 videos you're gonna have
half of them as as cat tricks and babies
learning to walk and the other half hour
music videos that's why three minutes
okay that's not the kind of video I'm
trying to make the stuff I like are more
like the TED Talks you guys seen a TED
talk video you haven't go look it up
it's amazing here are some of the most
inspirational motivating educational
videos and speeches from from some of
the greatest minds available today
online you look at those videos some
have millions of hits and none of them
are three minutes long we're talking 10
15 20 minutes long that's what I'm
playing in and the fact that somebody
thinks that just because the average
popular video with 253 that a video
can't be longer than three minutes and
be successful but it blows my mind and
the fact is it's already up and it's
doing well in three weeks it meters been
up for three weeks it has a hundred
thousand views already today it hits
100,000 views and that's with no
advertising no promotion I'm not out
there buying ads for people to see this
this is just taking off
it's been going crazy with with people
giving it likes and thumbs ups and
sharing and commenting and email and
people write in to me and say Evan thank
you so much for making this video it
really helped me today it's great to
know that other people are feeling the
same way that I do that's important to
me that's why I'm doing this that's the
reason behind my business it's helping
entrepreneurs get past their fears and
doubts and believe in themselves that's
what it's all about for me and that
wasn't enough it's been translated into
13 languages not by me I only speak
English but by people who watch the
video loved it so much that they decided
they had to translate it into their own
language you go on there you can find it
in arabic bulgarian chinese croatian
Dutch French German Italian Persian
polish Russian Spanish oh oh I forgot I
forgot though it's three minutes so it
can't be successful it kills me it just
kills me and I can't like I don't care
about this little man but what bothers
me that he exists because what if I had
gone to him before made the video what
if you go to somebody before you launch
your idea and he tell you some stupid
statistic like this and that gets you
down and hold you back from launching
don't listen to the little man believe
in yourself and follow through I have
Ronnie on the line Ronnie where are you
from and how can I help how you doing
I'm from lubbers New Jersey New Jersey
welcome to the program what's going on
how can I help
good good I have a question I have a
have a detective agency we've relied a
lot on walk-in business but we've we
started developing some of our our web
pages and I really wanted to know I have
a lot of people coming in offering me
deals to a you know to expand our
business online by joining all these
programs that cost thousands of dollars
a month but I see there with all the
social media that's out there what do
you recommend the best ways for me to
get the word out on my page without
having to subscribe to all these
services oh that's it that's a great
question and for a lot of people
associate you haven't done anything yet
before it's you haven't really relied on
it because I've had
it yeah it's a huge unknown barely scare
and you can drop tons of money going in
the wrong direction the first thing I
would recommend is figuring out which
channel best fits what you're all about
and where your customers are okay so you
know does video lend itself well to what
you do if it does you can go on YouTube
right can you do things with pictures
should you be on Facebook or should you
be on Twitter how I would start it's
thinking about where do your customers
hang out where your customers spending
most of their time because social media
if you're marketing and networking with
them it's just like any other networking
event you want to hang out where your
customers are if your customers are
Twitter then you want to be in that
party right if your customers are party
how I first got started was I subscribe
to all the channels just just to lock in
my name you know you don't want another
company taking your name and owning your
Twitter account but from there I just
started listening so you can subscribe
to Twitter for example to all the
searches that might come in that have
your company name so our people already
talking about you on Twitter yes so you
want to be a part of that conversation
right if you know people are talking
about you on Twitter
worst case like easiest simplest
solution is just recognize them and
thank them you want to thank your
champions people who are spreading the
word that's how I first started or
mentioning my website and I just I just
said thank you thank you for sharing cuz
you could give them a little bit of
recognition they're gonna want to do it
again and again and again oh okay you
are asked the questions then you want to
get involved right be able to answer
them it's just another way for people to
attack so if you know the people are
already engaging with you on Twitter
start there well we'll give it a shot
just start by listening that's your step
one you don't have to go crazy and say
I'm gonna ban you and everything else
I'm doing and just spend five hours a
day on Twitter but that's not gonna work
right but just start by listening
and then once you get a little familiar
with it start thinking about what are
you really good at what are you an
expert at and how can you share some of
the expertise on Twitter so Twitter for
example it's all really short but you
don't have a lot of characters to talk
about no no that a lot do you recommend
like on our web pages to use more video
than text and more you know something
that will catch your more attention than
having them to read through a bunch of
text as opposed to just hearing it
straight to a presentation I love video
I think because I'm a visual learner I
think a lot of people are visual
learners but you have to think does your
business lend itself well the video and
do you have the resources right now to
do video relict at their Twitter just
have to type in 140 characters it's not
a lot of work to do a video or to make
it good could have a great impact but
you have to invest the time and energy
to make it happen excellent appreciate
appreciate the help no problem good luck
and keep me posted
you guys thanks take care all right
thanks Ronnie Cheers and for everybody
listening no social media can be really
scary at the start if you haven't done
anything before and it's this big new
world that you don't know how to get
into don't let that fear kind of hold
you back it can be really powerful but
it's not the answer to everything and
the best way to get started is just
small start small get your names on all
the accounts that you own that nobody
else can take your name right I am Evan
Carmichael on Twitter nobody else can
take my twitter handle cuz I own it
that's how you get started and then just
start listening see what people are
talking about see people are mentioning
your company see people are talking
about you and either in a good way or in
a bad way and just join the conversation
that doesn't take long that's not going
to take you hours a day I know you're
stretched on time this is not a huge
commitment and as you see a little bit
of engagement as you recognizing your
champions then you could start so what
else can you add how can you be a
thought leader how can you showcase your
expertise
and you know it's worth doing because
you already have a little bit of
traction don't go crazy on Twitter
sharing tons of stuff if you have no
audience nobody's paying attention to
you so that's the evolution I recommend
baby steps make sure it works get some
traction build up from there don't make
it some crazy huge project that's
overwhelming all-consuming and you end
up wanting to give it up for somebody
else to do and you pay them a whole
bunch of money it doesn't work out this
is something you can handle but starting
slowly today's episode is about dealing
with the little man the guy who's just
trying to stomp out your ideas tell you
you're not good enough tells you that
you're not going to achieve your dreams
of it's just not possible and I'm
talking about a little man and what my
life was trying to hate on one of the
ideas that I'm doing one thing that you
gotta understand about the little man
you know that he always wants to be
right and even if you show him that what
you're doing is working
he's still not gonna believe you so I
showed my little man that hey you know
what you see me on this video this is
never gonna work it's longer than three
minutes and that check out all the views
is getting check out all the reaction is
getting and he writes back and he says
Evan you're faulty in your luggage in
your logic your faulty in your logic are
you it's so ridiculous I can't even say
it properly right it's crazy you know
what if you get somebody who's just
hating on your idea use it as fuel like
Tony said in and I'm and a segment a
couple times ago use it as fuel right
you're gonna have these people who who
will tell you that it's not possible
you're not gonna make it and the only
way to show them is to go out and do it
and here's a newsflash okay even if you
go and you hit your goal they're gonna
say yeah yeah you could do that but you
can't get to the next step
my goal with this video is a million
plus views a million plus views I hit a
hundred thousand you know what little
man is gonna say oh yeah a hundred
thousand whatever that's nothing anybody
can hit a hundred thousand three weeks
that's nothing but you can't hit a
million right and when I hit a million
even tell me something else yeah I
millions easy but you can't get the next
step that's that's just how little man
works that's how he thinks
and he's keeping you down don't listen
to the little man I got time for one
last caller I have Joey on the line Joey
where are you sobbing how can I help
are you doing all around New York about
20 years around going on
thank you I listen the little man that's
that I'm dealing with the little man
every day I I had a lot of ideas and you
know one of the ideas I have is putting
all my talents into one best you know
doing the comedy DJing parties and doing
ventriloquism and karaoke and so I'm
doing it all in one party yeah the funny
thing is is I'm sure I have a website
that I put up and I'm not getting any
business in this great idea of mine and
it's been about a year now I get one or
two you know I'll get the DJ job so I'm
like I'm trying to do the all-around is
it any party I don't know I'm just
putting too much into one too many eggs
in one basket but I'm not getting any
new business do you know trying to
trying to do this big entertainment I'm
getting a lot of simple parties and I
don't know how the connection right now
yeah I'm trying to get to the next level
that's Apple more money just for more
exposure more work I didn't think it's a
great idea tell these guys who just want
a DJ party that I also want to throw in
ventriloquism yeah I don't know man it's
just that they're not gold for it you
know and you know it works for kids
parties you know works at kids parties
um I think a lot of people just a scared
yeah I don't know i how do you convince
you know how do you convince your your
customers on something that would be
really a great a great party that I
think it's too risky for them or
something doesn't make any sense yeah
and people are afraid people are afraid
to do something out of the norm
especially if they haven't seen it yet
what I would hear is what if you have
your et parties already go I would try
to inject some of these things and just
put it in there don't charge for him
just put it in there and start building
your name up
the guy who also does this because if
you're convinced that it's gonna work
right you know that by having karaoke in
there it's gonna work and make the party
amazing right throw it in in a small way
test it out and get the reaction because
a lot of the business for this kind of
service and you get word-of-mouth right
so actually come to the party they love
it man you got a higher Joey that guy
was killer right exactly that's what I'm
trying to get to that level and it's
just people just it's the risk I guess
it's the risk they don't want you to
ruin that party you know they wanted it
so simple and they don't want to make a
judgment call on what of the other
things you think you can do well we'll
work with your audience and throw it in
their booth just slow it in just throw
it in and don't don't even let them know
just destroy it into it happen put it in
and don't charge for it yet no don't say
I put that as part of your pitch yet
because people are scared of it
show that it works and the people who
are at the party who experience that
because no other day does this variance
that they're going to want to hire you
and eventually you're going to be able
to charge a lot more for these extra
services exactly it's just getting to
the point of having people see it and
trust it and word-of-mouth and I just
can't get to that I just can't you know
it's been a year now they're trying to
do this let me give you an example okay
I work with a big company big telco and
they asked me to write a blog post to
their website okay they wanted 300 words
instead of writing 300 words I gave them
way more I give them 1500 words I gave
them a video and something that nobody
else is doing for them and they were
they were afraid of it
I didn't I just did it I mean it
god-killer results like that'sthat's the
rub your thing has to work right right
you got to be confident that it's gonna
work you got a tailor to your audience
and know that it's going to work right I
went from charging 500 bucks for that
service to 2,500 bucks to that service
okay I write a blog post and do a video
right like you get 5 times increase
because nobody else does now what I do
anybody can write 300 words anybody can
write be a party right you
have that special sauce that flavor to
see inside me Joey no I don't want those
other guys I want Joey because he does
all this other stuff but you guys show
that it works right
how about whatever your next Marty is
can we not figure out like what is the
one thing pick up pick from that list if
it's if it's the karaoke or the
ventriloquism or the comedy whatever it
is pick that one thing that fits that
audience and just bump it in there
just do it you're taking a risk but
you're taking a risk on yourself that's
the best risk you can take yeah it'll be
a risk for myself as well but I guess
that's the only way to really get past
this hawk enough you know I'm stuck in a
crossroads you know you got to do it you
got to believe in yourself man just go
for it I like it let me know how it goes
I'm excited for you I will I will Thanks
nice there's a for everybody listening
the best way to build your business is
to combine your passions because
everybody can be a DJ right doesn't take
a lot to be a DJ you need to have
something different something unique and
bring more of yourself to it so that
you're the DJ that everybody asks for
we've got this awesome mix of skills and
talents so figure what that is and you
have to amend it scary right like what
if you lose your client what do they
don't like what you do they don't have
the confidence of seeing advanced yeah I
want that extra thing at my party but
you got to have the confidence believe
in yourself and go for it because you
got to take a chance on yourself we're
already at a time it's crazy how quickly
this show goes I want to thank my
producers Lauren Fernanda you guys Rock
I'm on again in two weeks
remember don't let the little man keep
you down stay strong these two weeks
thank you guys and I'll see you soon